over last is there is a huge news about
outbreak of norovirus in Kerala South
India and from the media newspaper and
the news channels it has been evident
that there are more than 11 deaths in
this neba virus infection so what is
nipple virus how deadly it is is there
any vaccine how does it affect the human
how to stay safe is there any treatment
of that all these questions should be
answered in this video so stay tuned and
watch this video so from the WHO
guidelines it has been shown these red
mark stones at the top risk zones of
Nipah virus outbreak and the stripe
lines at the potential other risk zones
now is it the first time nipa outbreak
in India the answer is no Nipah virus
was first found in Malaysia and the
outbreak happened in 1998 in Campo
sungai nipa after that in 1999 there was
a severe outbreak of nipa in Singapore
in 2001 there was a super outbreak in
Siliguri West Bengal and several people
were dead in nip outbreak in 2004 in
Bangladesh again Nipah virus reoccurred
in West Bengal in nadia district in 2007
and after that the evidence of nip
outbreak is from Kerala India how deadly
is Nipah virus it has been seen from the
statistical data that in outbreak at
2001 out of 66 case 45 were dead
so 68 percent was the fatality rate from
2004 in Bangladesh and outbreak in 2005
mean again another district in
Bangladesh has shown that the fatality
rate is almost 74 to 75 percent that
means Nipah virus is quite deadly and
the mortality rate is pretty high now
what is the deeper virus Nipah virus is
one of the RNA virus that means
provirus use RNA as its genetic material
and its family name is param
accessibility and in simple words you
know the other family members of this
family
they are moms and missile virus and the
deadliest family member of this family
is this Nipah virus and Nipah virus has
negative sense single-stranded RNA has
its genetic material apart from that it
has several surface glycoprotein which
they use to invent into the host cells
that means into the human cells now if
we see the Nipah virus
there are several glycoproteins some
glycoproteins marked in black here is
known as fusion protein which helped the
virus to infuse itself in inside the
human cells and there are attachment
protein which help the virus to attach
to a host cell now host cell membrane
has receptors which can interact with
these viral membrane glycoproteins and
this interaction lead to the entry of
the viral genetic material inside the
host once the genetic material is inside
the host it can replicate make even more
virus army of virus and invade several
other cells of the body
now how Nipah virus spread from bat to
human let's say a bat is eating a fruit
from the tree and the bat is affected by
the Nipah virus so they could be a
carrier of Nipah virus now from the
saliva and other body fluid of the bat
the Nipah virus could be transmitted to
the human for example a human is eating
a fruit which is lying on the ground and
it is previously eaten and contaminated
with the saliva saliva of the bat could
allow the transmission of the disease to
human the disease could be also
transmitted by other cattles like peak
let's say the peak is consuming a
contaminated contaminated fruit or
somehow it is coming in contact with the
salivary secretion or other watery
secretion of the back it is getting
infected it would work as a
and transmitted that disease to human
once a human is affected it can spread
the virus by aerosol or from other body
liquids it can spread the virus among
the human community and this is how the
virus could spread rapidly and affect
other humans now what are the symptoms
of Nipah virus infection the first and
foremost symptoms is severe respiratory
infection like severe coughing and
sneezing etc also it comes along with
high fever and severe headache there is
mental confusion there is dizziness
there is also end if you like this like
syndromes for example there is
inflammation or a burning sensation in
the head let's take a look at the most
two complications associated with this
nipple virus infection one of the
complications is the airway infection
Nipah virus could get transmitted to
another human by aerosol so in its a
droplet infection so nipple virus can go
inside of the body of the human by its
Airways and in the Airways the LV in the
Airways of the lungs it can come in
contact with a blood vessel once it come
contact with the blood vessel it can get
inside the blood vessel it can do couple
of deadly thing one of the thing is it
can produce severe inflammation that
means alarming the immune system and
that's why there is a burning sensation
in the Airways it can also cause
necrosis of the blood capillaries that
means destroying the blood vessels and
all these things can ultimately lead to
severe breathing problems apart from the
breathing symptoms and the respect
inspiratory chronic infection there are
other symptoms as well and Nipah virus
is one of the deadly virus which can
attack our CNS our central nervous
system our brain but how does Nipah
virus manage to go to our brain
there are two ways that me providers can
goes to our go to our brain one of the
way as it is going inside through a
respiratory trip it can follow the track
of the olfactory nerve and go to the
brain and it it's also and go to the
brain by the blood stream it can cross
the blood-brain barrier and blood-brain
barrier is a safety wall for the brain
and it doesn't allow all the pathogens
that is roaming around in the
bloodstream to get entry into the brain
but it breaks the wall
it breaks the safety wall and can
potentially damage it and there will
increase the risk of secondary
infections as well also Nipah virus can
infect the nerve cells that means the
neurons and also the microglia now
microglia our immune cells in the brain
once they are affected they are more
primed they secrete alarming signals
that would draw attention of other
microglia and other immune cells in the
brain and all these things create a huge
inflammatory response in the brain and
that causes the burning sensation also
the vascular permeability of the
capillaries surrounding the brain is
increased in case of Nipah virus
infection that means in simple word the
blood capillaries are using up that
means loosening of the blood capillary
can give rise to fluid exchange and that
leads to swimming and other inflammatory
responses this is how Nipah virus can
attack our respiratory system and the
central nervous system but how to
understand that one person is affected
by ternopil virus or not is there any
diagnostic test for that sorry but
currently there is no diagnostic test
that can identify a virus infection only
from the patient bird blood sample by
sophisticated medical tests National
Institute of violent biology in mume can
still detect whether there is a
infection in the bloodstream or not but
those tests are not available to public
and those are pretty costly so
what is in our hand is a symptoms
symptoms are the only way to identify
the infection so don't ignore any
symptom to be a casual disease like
cough or cold so if you have any symptom
which is similar like that that I have
described so quickly see your doctor or
see the nearby health center immediately
now is there any vaccine to Nipah virus
no currently there is no vaccine to
Nipah virus so then what are the
treatment options the only treatment
option right now is to keep the patient
under intensive medical care under
intensive medical care itself the body
of the patient can fight back to the
virus and this there is a possibility
there is a rare chance that the patient
patient could revive the infection and
get better but scientists throughout the
world is trying to develop antibodies
against this protein which the virus use
to get into the cells but those vaccines
or those therapies are not available to
market those are in still clinical
trials stage so currently there is no
vaccine intensive medical care is only
option so what are the precautions that
we can take to make our family and make
ourselves safe first of all don't eat
any fruit that is contaminated by back
or that seems to be contaminated by any
animal or consumed by any animal
secondly don't drink common drinks like
2d or date-palms app so all these things
could be contaminated with bat saliva or
UV and since that saliva renewing could
contain the virus so it increases the
risk to spread the disease
once in anybody's infected by the virus
make sure that he or she is in isolation
and also touching the patient should be
with gloves or proper facemask otherwise
this disease can spread very rapidly
normal hygiene and washing our clothes
and utensils properly and sterilizing
them could be another important things
to do now if you liked this video is
give it a quick thumbs up don't forget
to share and help to spread awareness
among the people thank you